en terme de buzz c'est réussi et les
réactions sont fortes
un quarteron de généraux en retraite
pour reprendre l'expression du général
de gaulle a publié une tribune dans la
presse pour dénoncer le délitement de la
france sous l'effet distille de
l'islamisme ou encore d'un antiracisme
dont l'objectif serait une guerre
raciale et appelant de façon à peine
voilée les militaires encore en poste à
se dresser contre ce délitement or
participer à un mouvement
insurrectionnel ou même seulement
l'encourager et puni par le code pénal
et c'est sur ce fondement que jean luc
mélenchon en tant qu'autorité publique
fait usage de son devoir de saisir le
procureur de la république en note au
passage que c'est le même jean luc
mélenchon qui twittait dans un contexte
de heurts entre j les jeunes et forces
de l'ordre que l'insurrection est un
droit et un devoir mais ce qui est dit
dans cette tribune relève t-il du code
pénal une phrase précise a pu être
interprétée comme un appel au coup
d'état
je cite si rien ne change 19 généraux il
faudra que les militaires en activité
agissent pour protéger nos valeurs
civilisationnelles et sauvegarder nos
compatriotes sur le territoire national
fin de citation
est-ce véritablement une incitation à
quoi que ce soit ou simplement du
catastrophisme de bistrot aux mots
soigneusement pesé en tout état de cause
un juge n'aurait pas le droit d'aller
lire entre les lignes pour trouver un
délit à tout prix
l'appel implicite au cou l'état paraît
bien difficile à extrapoler
juridiquement de cette tribune même si
médiatiquement il faut le dire c'est un
succès reste que ces anciens généraux
ont enfreint le code de la défense sur
le devoir de réserve des militaires et
sont passibles de sanctions
disciplinaires
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a annoncé le chef
d'état major des armées le général
lecointre